and now this is Oscar night
congratulations welcome to the
Oscars we're proud of all our nominees
God forbid anyone should think of this
as a
competition best achievement in
cinematography film editing cume design
the nominations are I'll open the
envelope and announce the winner well
how come you get to announce the winner
and the winner the winner is oh the
winner is and the osar goes to Street we
just wrote name down at a
habit my kids are watching this is
because Mommy works so hard thank you to
the academy the academy my mom I want to
thank everybody who makes movies now I'm
going home to cry hello gorgeous this is
the American dream this means so much to
me thank you thank you thank
you we just won an
Oscar together
w